[Music]
this isn't a hospital
it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
hello everybody hi hi
this is our first ever virtual comic con
interview how is it for you guys doing
like
paul h is now hall home h down to her
home what is that like for you guys
doing like a panel and all this stuff at
home
this is like haul the garage
i find it really funny when people say
that they're not getting used to
quarantine i'm like this is my life like
we're actually
inside for months until we're out
but there's advantages right like
there's certain advantages like i have
my cheese plate off to the side
yeah like i'm not wearing shoes right
now you don't know that
yep
okay jumping is um i want to know for
each of you what is your first
memory with x-men like what do you
remember my first memory is
definitely like wolverine the hairy
chest the hair
the claws that's my first one but what
is it for you guys
yeah i'm sorry mine was june gray's
veins on her face i
forgot the name of the actress she
played so brilliantly is
so terrifying to me um but yeah i think
it was in the same movie actually
i i really knew the comics before the
movies so in the 80s growing up my my
co-writer and i were always reading
marvel comics so
the x-men comics were a thing long
before there were any x-men movies
but uh i'd also say wolverine is
certainly the most iconic
character in in x-men and i remember him
vividly reading those as a kid
and i think this is probably the most
quintessential
comic-con question ever about what x-men
power would you most want to have
whichever x-men can fly i would do that
uh yeah i always like knight cooler uh
yeah
very cool also teleportation aspect to
it
yeah yeah i think magic like
what i like about like like popping in
and popping out is that you can just
disappear
from you know i mean now whenever you
know it's
without being able to travel it would be
really
it would be amazing i mean like i'm from
brazil so i'm in a different country i
would be like
boom at home yeah teleportation and time
travel would be two key things right now
yeah lisa could right now just start
teleporting between our screens
it would be so awesome like she's here
she jumps to you
maybe you guys that could be yeah
so for the actors what was your favorite
i mean obviously um i don't know your
familiarity with x-men when each of you
got the role but what was sort of your
favorite discovery about your character
either in researching it or in playing
the role
yeah i think for me um
you know initially you kind of joined
you know
uh when we were told we were joining
this it's like you know
this expectation of this kind of big
superhero film
uh the surprise on this was uh really
how
internal all these characters were uh
and how much we got to
create that and and use that to kind of
hold on to
uh just to play throughout this whole
thing um
so yeah really the internal idea of
powers and the idea
of what it means to be different and
have this like
you know uh kind of thing inside you
that you were struggling with
uh was like i did not think i'd be going
on that kind of journey
when i was kind of joining this movie i
thought it would be you know
a different experience but it was you
know
a bit more harrowing in that sense which
is always you know wonderful to kind of
play
i enjoy anybody else yeah it seems for
me from what i've seen so far that
there's
it's an emotional journey too that you
guys are all sort of grappling with
learning to deal with these powers and
that kind of thing but
and we really approached that the powers
were uh
not something cool to have but something
that would be pretty horrifying to have
if you woke up one day with powers and
you were hurting people with them
without
intending to yeah yeah that's the main
theme
in the in the i think even the comics is
like it's
it's more of something that keeps you
scared
of becoming rather than something you
want to hone and and
heroically become right like you
yeah one spot doesn't think of becoming
sunspot he's like how do i not
light people on fire
that like plays i think for all of our
characters
uh a huge deal in the narrative like you
know
um how do how does that play
into um sorry i totally
lost my training how does how
how does that play uh into the
relationship of these characters being
so different and are getting along
to okay we need to figure out who we are
and come together to destroy the
the big you know i can't fair
i think everybody knows there's a
barrier to that yeah
i think we know i'm like did i say that
i can't say that i say that
i know you have to always keep straight
what am i allowed to say what am i not
allowed to say
um so for you guys i know like you
jumped into this
and i know you when you were filming it
you were all i think staying in a small
hotel together did it feel like a
sleep-away camp in a sense and was it
also
like did you have a new mutant's boot
camp
yeah it was kind of a boot camp being in
the hotel in the
yeah we had a three week process and uh
yeah i mean we're all in this
you know in the middle of nowhere in a
marriott
and yeah it was it was interesting
because you are having these
you know in in the story these
characters people are kind of
trapped in this facility and having to
kind of you know
bond with each other and then we were
trapped in a hotel having to
fund with each other i think our
experience was more pleasant than the
movie you know
yeah we're terrifying the marriott or
being in like the
you know locked into the place together
honest answer
uh but yeah we also got to go through uh
you know some
some uh personal uh uh physical physical
training
uh which was nice we did that together
and and you know
again because the teenagers it wasn't
like you know gotta make these guys huge
uh but it was nice to kind of bond in uh
yeah that kind of way we were able to
physical physically work together
i don't know who was who was like the
the person from the get-go that you were
all like oh my gosh this person's
getting it really quickly
like this person's like getting all the
stunts or whatever you had to do like
who had done i feel like a couple of
them had done stunt work before
right wire work and all that amazing
give me that sword i can do something
yeah
[Laughter]
like you know i mean i think you used to
be a dancer so she kind of has
really good rhythm and movement so to
see her really quickly just take that
kind of on it was really cool yeah yeah
and then behind the scenes what was what
was like the sleep away camp like were
you guys bonding at night
blue what were you guys up to what were
you guys doing oh yeah we
we all pretty much hung out every night
yeah we
watched tv together we made each other
dinners
um we had to share a bottle of wine we'd
talk about everything that was happening
what we were doing we helped each other
with cell tapes just
um everything and then we all went on to
set together
um sometimes we would go play um what do
we go play at that bar where they every
week would have like trivia or whatever
that's right and we went to ball games
and things like that we did
some stuff like that we went into boston
like into the city together
quite a few times we all saw uh dunkirk
hilarious actually
everybody just got married right
on the on the seventh
nolan street have it he wants you to see
it on the biggest screen you possibly
can
drive as you said with all movies yeah
true you can help me um josh for you
i know this was your baby you know to
use to use a christopher nolan phrase
this the inception of this whole sort of
superhero
horror genre sort of hybrid was yours
what was the initial
what was your initial pitch meeting like
like when you pitched this movie
and then how did you you know in filming
a superhero movie how does it change
things when you're bringing a horror
element into it
well it's it's uh so i mean i wrote this
with my best friend who i've known since
the day i was born our moms are best
friends and we're from virginia
and we read marvel comics growing up and
uh i just always liked these kind of
dark supernatural
new mutants stories they were just so
different the artwork and everything's
so different from anything i'd seen in
comics before other than like
vertigo comics uh really dark dc stuff
um and to see
superheroes in those things i hadn't
seen before
we were really just trying to capture
that so it's it's not like we sat there
and said
we're gonna go figure out a way to make
a comic book horror movie it was really
the material
sort of dictated that it'd be a comic
book horror movie
and then we added sort of more elements
than that like uh
you know the romance between danny and
rayne and uh a lot of kind of the john
hughes joss whedon kind of humor stuff
that's coming of age stuff uh
all that stuff just kind of became a
melting pot for us to make
hopefully a comic book movie that wasn't
like anyone you've seen before that has
sort of its own identity
uh and can kind of stand on its own
separate from all that stuff and still
be its own thing
yeah are we gonna see any like are we
going to have surprises or when you see
a lot of easter eggs and there's
are there going to be any marvel tie-ins
josh oh sure i mean you know it's
it's absolutely connected to the x-men
universe we're just uh
we just had the uh we were in the
unfortunate position of being the very
last movie
after the franchise had already been
closed out with dark phoenix
which was really supposed to come out
after ours but because of the merger
they put everything into it to get it
done
uh i don't know man i sort of like that
it's by itself and isn't part of it
other than sort of if you watch it you
know you're in the x-men universe and
professor x is out there somewhere but i
kind of like that it's its own thing it
doesn't
uh it doesn't uh depend on those movies
in any way to tell the story
didn't you initially pitch it with a
comic book didn't you create a comic
book for your pitch
nate and i made like a 60-page pdf for
fox that sort of took them through kind
of like a a series of movies about these
characters that each one would be its
own
unique horror movie and the first one
was a rubber reality horror movie which
is what we want to made
and then for for each of you um is there
an x-men movie that kind of means the
most to you as a fan
for i really loved logan i mean i
thought like the way that they did that
and i think the hugh jackman's work of
like grounding the character so much
that it's kind of
like you can feel it you can connect
with
you know his background story you know
all that
i really love the way that they did all
the action and and the way that
the film is i really loved it yeah i'd
say logan and dave's the future past are
my favorite
x-men movies uh dave patch the one with
quicksilver running around the room and
all that
yeah i also love the first one the very
first one about something
so i mean it was a taste of something
new that
uh we wouldn't know back then that there
would be like 11 movies after that
that would change uh fans forever i mean
wasn't just
little little uh little magneto bending
back all the
all the all the bars of the gates of uh
auschwitz or whatever was so powerful i
mean
yes definitely image yeah
charlie what about you yeah uh for me i
guess again the first one
and uh just because i was a teenager
back then and you know and watching
those movies
really yeah it's just it's there when
they're probably well it can be one of
the most exciting i guess
that projection where you come out and
you're running around pretending you
have told
um you know things like that so yeah if
funny watching this you know we got to
see
movie back in march and there was a you
know a real
moment in the movie uh when i had this
moment where like a
little 13 year old in me who watched
that original x-men movie was just like
it kind of kicking and uh kind of
experience
yeah you just gave me chills thought
hair on my arm just
said that because i know what that's
like i just watched the first one
yesterday again
it's like so iconic at this point um and
then um my last question for you guys
you've all been part of
other shows or other series what does
the x-men
fandom how does that compare to other
things that you've worked on
i'd say without the movie even being out
yet that they're the biggest fan base
i've encountered and the movie isn't
even out yet
way bigger than than all the rest of
them uh
and people's kind of devotion to it and
how much they
that they want to see it hasn't died the
embers are still strong and all that so
they still seem psyched and excited
which is great
yeah i think so yeah i think i think the
same thing as you josh i think like it's
it's really special how
fans for comics they're really really
passionate and i think that x-men is
such a strong comic that
you know people connect with the
character and their questions and all
that
i do believe they're really good fans
like really really
um committed yeah yeah um yes i mean
obviously
you know being in stranger things and
having that fandom which is
this is huge you know i've had that kind
of exposure to
you know very committed dedicated large
fan base and
you know when i've been out and around
and most of the time people
just you know they shout stranger things
or jonathan at me
but it is really interesting when you do
get someone who you know
in the film they come up hey you're
cannonball right and uh
yeah i get just that kind of like yeah
that like i'm like man i love this it's
like
a lot of times all the older all the
dudes to me it wasn't about the stature
of
the fandom it was more about you know
even if you're if you're not like a
die-hard fan of x-men
i've probably been touched by its
stories
uh and how that relates to people in
real life and becoming
growing up in your body changing your
insecurities
uh heightening and uh
that's been at least to me very personal
and how the x-men
have impacted me uh back in the day and
still
do um to me that's that's the power of
x-men in a way
yeah that was stan i mean that was their
intention originally was to
talk about the civil rights movement and
minorities and everything else so it's
just sort of gone on down the line
it's amazing isn't it 2020 here we are
and it's so relevant
totally more than ever
[Laughter]
and i think that's what you know i'm
looking forward to in seeing this film
is sort of
that stuff that they were dealing with
in the 60s even just like coming of age
and like dealing with
you know what makes you different can
make you absolutely special unique and
beautiful
i think that's sort of the message that
i'm i'm looking forward to hopefully
seeing in this film
yeah and i think it's true about
accepting people flaws and all
you know what i mean
you